uh
this particular film i did not know what
the speed was going to be and that
terrified me
um so what i did is i structured it into
an improvisation
that is separated by about 22 individual
violin pieces and what i do is i
improvise in between those pieces and
then set up based on what's going on in
the movie i set up
the
tempo and the key
and
the meter
and then give nikki an introduction and
then uh she
at the appropriate time
jumps in with the violin and then
there's a set piece of music that's been
written
hemorrhage is one of those pieces that i
learned
i you know i played it when i was
younger without knowing its meaning
really and then studying it again in
university about what you know the the
actual impact of american music on
dvorak who's coming from from you know
the eastern block of europe and how much
the blues really influenced him and how
much that american music or what he his
understanding of american music meant to
him so
playing it now i have a better sense of
what humorous is as as from a
perspective of the violinist when they
transcribed it for uh solo violin which
wasn't you know
done and it's it's just
it's it's definitely something i've
grown into now yeah it's interesting too
the dvorak piece the humor the famous
piece humorous the one that goes
that we use for this
um
she hit on something that's really
important it's it's
based on american song forms and it's
with dvorak you know his new world
symphony he uses american song forms as
well right but humoresque is is clearly
american aba
form
song form
so it was kind of interesting as a
revelation
from
from a performer's standpoint
um you have to be really fast on your
feet and you have to especially as an
accompanist
and as a solo accompanist too sometimes
doesn't get to see the film at all
you have to be able to to read the film
the second something hits the screen you
have to figure out there's a there's a
gun there and there's a knife there and
the audience might not see that but you
have to be a master at scanning a
picture
and figuring out what's next and um
that's probably the most important skill
set it's just it's just being alert and
being on your toes and always thinking
ahead you have to think you know you
might be playing a romantic scene now
but you know there's going to be a
villain coming in otherwise you don't
have a movie
um
so you you're always anticipating and as
an accompanist and as a composer
um you're trying to figure out what
you know what key am i in like if i'm in
a flat and the villain comes in i want
to be in f minor but i might want to be
in d minor now how do i get from a flat
to d minor well i do that through an e7
chord going to an a7 chord and then add
a b flat and i'm in d minor
that's the stuff that goes on in your
head
when you're when you're playing and
these and when you're composing two but
when you and i'm a lot of this is
improvisational tonight
so that's the kind of stuff that goes in
my head it's like i'm an f minor and
nicki's got a q coming up in a major
in less than five seconds and i've gotta
shift into three different keys before
then get into the so it's the skill set
for me as an accompanist is speed you
know like how fast can i think a lot of
it has to do with timing and a lot of
people don't have that kind of timing
i think uh and
they're there's takes
a lot more concentration that uh you
know as opposed to sitting in a in a
studio session you have a few times to
make that take
we have one shot at this and you have to
go for an hour
hour 10 you know longer and you have to
keep the concentration up i think that
that is one of those drawbacks for a lot
of musicians because they can't focus
for that for extended period you know
periods of time where you have to be
able to think
you know bars measures cues ahead
you